[Música]
de hecho lo cuánta gente aquí
consigue el producto
sí
buenas tardes estoy nervioso y ayudarme
comentó ya don freddy presentó la
bicicleta
mi nombre
y francisco i
yo soy un tipo atrevidísimo porque una
vez
unos amigos me iba a decirle amigos me
dio conté que eran ciclistas ya
establecidos a decirle mira yo voy a
hacer una marca de bicicletas
y ellos pensaban que era un chiste yo no
es una marca de bicicleta y uno
es todavía amigo me dice henry
quien te va a comprar una bicicleta o
sea es de marc que es el michael jordan
del ciclismo un fracaso
el lemon que es el americano más exitoso
del tour de francia fracaso a ti quién
te va a comprar una bicicleta
yo dije mira yo no sé yo lo que quiero
es hacerla yo quiero empezar a hacer una
marca de bicicleta
pero esa historia se remonta muchísimos
años atrás cuando yo era un niño de un
mes y medio de nacido que estando en la
cuna de mi casa de mi casa yo agarré un
alambre eléctrico y me lo metí en la
boca
y me electrocuté
y me amputaron el audio de abajo yo me
crié sin que el labio de abajo en villa
juana toda la cuerda quedaba bien que el
barrio me dejaban a mí
entonces jugaron nueva que voy yo era
malo haciendo cuentos yo era malo
nosotros hacíamos muchísimos deportes
que no existen por ejemplo yo me ha
creado el cementerio y los domingos por
la mañana nosotros íbamos a lopo la
tumba eso era un deporte pero yo era
malo en tu visto yo era malísimo
yo era también malo con las niñas a todo
el mundo una noviecita y yo siempre en
los lados y me acompleja uno cuando el
niño se acompleja fácil
y un día sentado allí en el quicio mi
casa pasa este tipo en una bicicleta da
un salto
[Música]
y ves a una muchacha y sigue igual
y eso es lo que yo quiero hacer
y le dije a mi mamá que me regalara una
bici mamis un esfuerzo grandísimo empeño
un televisor zen y que tenía y me compro
una bici para mí para mi hermana porque
a mi hermano lo dejaron rey no nos daban
entonces la visita de los dos
y la bicicleta señores me cambió la vida
porque yo empecé a hacer un muchacho
libre yo agarré la bicicleta y me empecé
a perder en la ciudad
la primera vez que yo vi el fármaco lon
yo dije guau eso yo lo veía en los
libros
y ahí empezó mi iglesia y se metieron
con la bici ya creciendo yo dejé la
bicicleta porque aquí montar bicicleta
muy difícil el sol a mí si yo tenía pelo
que tener lo que yo tenía mucho pelo
entonces él me maltrataba el pelo me
empezaron a salir pinilla yo decía pero
no me van a se cansa otra vez la
muchacha
y de la bici y al dejar la bici yo
empecé a entrar en vacíos en mi vida que
yo no sabía por qué era
cuando yo tenía 18 años y querías el
mercadólogo de pollo querías el doctor
una vez quería ser veterinario pero nada
de eso me llenaba
y una tarde así de diciembre me dijo la
nueva york nueva york
y nos mudamos para nueva york nueva york
de la ciudad maravillosa nueva york te
saca lo mejor de ti porque todo es duro
el frío es duro el calor de lectura
trabajar es duro el nivel de
responsabilidad que tú tienes que llevar
ahí porque hay un régimen de
consecuencia o sea tú no paga a la luz
de la coltán no tú no puedes de quedar
es un tipo bueno yo no encontraba que yo
era por años me metí en los 20
yo era vendedor yo era camarógrafo todas
las profesiones que podían haber en el
mundo la tenía yo pero ninguna me
apasionaba
llega a los 30 así
lo peor del mundo cuando te llega a los
30 32 33 años que tus contemporáneos
todos tienen una profesión está cansado
tienen hijos
le gusta lo que hacen y tu perrito que
hace yo yo yo soy camarógrafo pero tú
estabas trabajando vendiendo cervezas y
también pero yo te hace el tío imagino
que mucha gente aquí ha pasado por eso
no se pierde inclusive hay gente que
tienen profesiones que dicen yo no
quiero hacer eso yo quiero hacer otra
cosa
siendo camarógrafo una vez yo
conocí una muchacha relajando una
italiana un lunes
y el mal te llame dice vamos a la mañana
hace un frío era un febrero
y ese mal te lo dije no yo no va a salir
de una turista esta tipo lista se va a
me rompe el corazón
además está muy frío y yo no tengo
cuarto
y no fui yo no fui yo la dejé esperando
y el miércoles esa niña me mandó un
email así lindísimo
y tú sabes que soy vitales y yo tenía la
tarjeta de crédito que era mi patrimonio
de vida
si uno siempre tiene un clavo y yo he
entrado tarjeta y compré un pasaje para
italia el miércoles y el viernes
yo estaba en 100 y media ya sabéis yo no
sabía marcar el teléfono yo me encontré
un colombiano de colombia por favor
y yo no sé
y ella no lo creía y me cerraba mira yo
tengo ocupada y oh dios mío que yo hago
aquí siente a ti para canadá
yo he llevado elegir y bueno yo yo no
fui a italia atrás de ella yo fui a
italia detrás de mí detrás de
encontrarme
con quien yo quería hacer quien yo era
había mucha gente que me desean herido
tiene talento pero qué hacía yo con ese
talento que hace uno con lo que uno
tiene ciencia yo con mi talento yo con
mi talento que decía mis amigos yo no
siga nada con eso y era porque yo seguía
perdido
la italiana después de año y medio una
mañana así hermosa de primavera me dijo
no te amo anda y
y me voto
bueno recogí mi mote titos
me volvió a nueva york yo lo había
alquilado mi apartamento a alguien le
dije 'mira volví tiene que haber un
apartamento me dio mi apartamento y otra
vez las crisis existenciales pero ya
estábamos metiendo treinta y pico
y se metió al invierno me acuerdo y
estaba otra vez en otro oficio en nueva
york treinta y pico años después nevando
pasé a un tipo en una bicicleta llevando
una bicicleta guau ya dónde ha estado la
bicicleta todos estos años que yo he
estado que yo estado perdido
voy a meter otra vez la compré una vis y
empecé a montar pero ya no era la
necesidad de montar bicicletas y yo voy
a hacer una marca de bicicleta
ya le hice el cuento de mis amigos que
bueno eso se riesgos de tipo está loco
este tipo es un amante bicicleta
y empecé a indagar empecé a buscar gente
y encontré un chino maravilloso que me
ayudó yo le llamo a eso la solidaridad
del desconocido hay gente que está cerca
de ti que no es tan solidaria como gente
que está lejos de ti y yo me encontré
con eso con ese tipo que este tipo me
ayudó a hacer mis sueños sin conocerme
nunca lo hemos visto tenemos una
relación de 9 años y hablamos casi todos
los días y nunca lo hemos visto pero
señores ha sido súper extra archi
la primera vez que yo fui con mi
bicicleta donde un tipo vendérsela él me
dijo
porque yo tengo que comprar una
bicicleta y yo le dije así muy
espontáneamente porque yo no vendo
bicicleta no no yo estoy haciendo una
marca yo lo que quiero que tú la ponga
ahí y que la gente la vea y en verdad
eso era lo que yo quería yo quería que
la gente la viera
yo vacile mucho en asia la marca mucho
la primera que yo hice no tenía nada no
tenía letrero no tenía nada no tenía
nombre el nombre yo lo saqué de italia
de un pueblecito que se llama santa
andrea de montetxio
y vacilando con la única bicicleta que
tenía que se le enseñaba a todo el mundo
un tipo me dijo yo quiero uno
un primero de marzo del 2009
no espérate yo todavía déjame dame
tiempo el tipo dijo no no no no no
y me compro una bicicleta por ahí
y la tienen llamas que no me la quiere
vender aquí en los muy normales que de
vender y ese tipo me compro mi primera
bicicleta pero yo no tenía lo cual todo
pase 15 bicicleta que tenía que hacer yo
tenía una vendida yo tiene que vender 14
más para poder bueno me endeudé amigos
cercanos me prestaron billete parte de
ese billete yo lo use para pagar mis
rentas o tuvo que salir a pedir dinero
prestado otra vez para poder hacer la
bicicleta porque me decía oye y mi
bicicleta
y alguna visita hermosa por ahí anda
y eso de pillín se llama me compró la
visita empujó a yo empezar a hacer o
atreverme a hacer una cosa
que es difícil o sea tú puedes vender
cualquier cosa pero tú crear algo y que
la gente crea en eso sin tu ser un
competidor o alguien famoso
ha sido muy difícil la bici en nueva
york muy chulo el verano después viene
el frío invierno que yo voy a hacer esto
que inventarme algo que yo viví
pero la gente que compite en bicicleta
compra las bicicletas en el invierno
ahora mismo la gente está comprando la
bicicleta que va a usar en el invierno
en nueva york'
y yo vende todas mis bicicletas
se ve
la segunda vez que yo hice bicicleta
yo tiene ya que pintarla ponerle colores
ya un fotógrafo yo me cogiera bain en
serio pero yo no tenía dinero porque la
visita que fui a la entonces es un plan
maravilloso yo me voy con trabajo
de 17 check te lo contaba en cheque un
trabajo de trabajadores de trabajador
social valga la redundancia pues ellos
contaban los cheques y me dicen por qué
techos que cuentan los chiquillos porque
aquí yo lo que voy a durar son 17
cheques en el cheque 17 sólo con una
galleta alguien pasa algo para que me
voten y aquí
esos 17 che que la compañía empezó a
crecer ya crecer ya crecer ya crecer
tanto que eso 17h que se convirtieron en
casi cuatro años en que yo tenía que
trabajar todos los días de 9 de la
mañana a 5 de la tarde y dentro de mi
trabajo yo yo hacer mi lucha llama a la
gente molesta a la gente diseñar cosas
en fin y era por una amiga josefina que
me decía
se quema se quema
manito 58 que más
bien señores
yo he aprendido de todo esto es que no
importa
lo que tú quieres hacer si tú sabes que
tú quieres hacer eso uno
si eso que tú quieres hacer tú le le
mete en mente corazón
no hay nada que te diga la gente de
fuera incluyendo tus amigos que te
impidan lograr es yo hoy cuando vine la
gente estaba maravillada con la
bicicleta
yo sé que la hago a mí no me yo la veo
todos los días como cuando tú ves esto
lo día que el intento mujer sí pero ya
es bueno que tu bicicleta pero pero ha
sido tanta la gente que me ha dicho mira
tan orgulloso de ti tú vienes de aquí
tú sabes provincia visita que tú haces y
guau sea en serio todo eso es el resumen
de todo que yo he pasado en mi vida
todo lo que yo pasaba en mi vida
dejar la universidad no tener o no tener
esposa fracasar en un sinnúmero de
problemas todo eso se ha resumido en yo
tener una
una marca de bicicleta que ha empezado a
andar por el mundo sin darme cuenta
y yo espero que lo que yo le he dicho
hoy le haya cambiado la vida a alguien
yo puedo seguir hablando muchísimo pero
se está acabando el tiempo
cuando vayan a montar bicicleta no hagan
lo que yo hice que yo entré por ahí sin
casco
lo otro en la bicicleta las cosas son
más cerca de lo que ustedes piensan yo
vine en bicicleta del malecón vinieron
media hora de 18 minutos claro no
voladora me pasaron pasaron cerca la
seguridad de la 30 de marzo yo pensaba
que era más fácil tuve que pareja me
tuve que pararme en embarra payán
acoge aire sino y ahorita cuando se oye
también yo porque cogí vaya por ahí yo
me estaba ahogando
le voy a hacer la última última anécdota
que me ha pasado en la bicicleta los
otros días yo fui a panamá me invitaron
y yo soy un tipo me gustas al modesto no
está en la clínica si tranquilito
y yo tiene que llevar cuatro bicicletas
y las bicicletas pagan un pasaje ya
cuando tú llevas una maleta de bicicleta
y te cobran 200 dólares
y 200 dólares vueltas yo dije 4 y
si nosotros dinero entonces yo agarré la
de salma y la metí en maletas ella
andaba con un carro con cuatro maletas
rota porque se rompieron entonces cuando
llegó a panamá llegó más gente de nueva
york conmigo entonces yo llego y el tipo
llega y sé lo que van para de panamá que
vienen para él y francisco yo no no no
el de las bicicletas soy yo no aunque
sigue la esquina y él empezó a tener el
mundial me dejó una esquina tirado
o sea la madre mi mamá que siempre me
decía requisito afeitarte
enriquito cámbiate fue viniendo
y bueno el tipo de porque ha tenido el
mundo mejor que y vamos a ver si cabe
y me dieron y era una voladora de la de
aquí y abrieron una tablita que tiene un
lado
y ahí me senté yo con mi maleta así
y llegamos al hotel el tipo en el hotel
me dejó botado yo tuve como una gente
que me ayudara yo subí pero al otro día
había una rueda de prensa y cuando ese
señor me vio sentado en la mesa
él estaba ahí sentado en la mesa de la
rueda de prensa él me decía
hoy ya no viene a cabo la
la rueda de prensa y el tipo me dice
hacer ser yo soy un idiota yo soy medio
de ayote de un excusa si un vídeo te que
yo hubiese tipo cambiado hoy a ti te
diga si no sabes pero ya yo lo entiendo
que tú trae a tu cuerpo
de hoy tranquilo tranquilo
yo creo que te voy a pedir unas hojas yo
lo que no quiero depender mi trabajo
mira que acabo de llegar aquí a panamá
me han conseguido esta chamba yo no
quiero perder mi trabajo no no no te
preocupes por eso que si hubiese sido yo
tú yo hubiese sido lo mismo porque el
pasajero se conoce por sus maletas
señores muchas gracias
los quiero mucho
[Aplausos]